The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today, as I mentioned
to you in last lecture,
we're going to really be
focusing in quite some depth
into this paper by Sunney Xie.
So I would say that it is one
of my all time favorite papers.
And in particular
from the standpoint
of discussing a
paper in class, I
think it is
absolutely wonderful.
It is, I think, clearly written.
It explains why that
did all these things.
And they checked all
sorts of possible sources
of perhaps being lead astray.
And I think it was a
huge amount of work,
and it was a technical tour
de force when it came out.
So before this, I would say
single molecule biophysics,
by which I mean both single
molecule fluorescence,
i.e., detection, as well as
single molecule manipulation,
were almost exclusively
in vitro techniques.
So we took purified
components, and then we
studied the fluorescence,
or the mechanical properties
and so forth, of these molecules
in the equivalent of a test
tube.
But really, in glass
slides, where we just
had to purified components,
so no know living cells.
And I think we got a lot of
insight into the dynamics
of molecular motors,
transcription, translation,
and so forth.
And I think that many
of us in the field
thought that this paper was
essentially not possible.
I did my Ph.D in the
single molecule area,
from of 2002 to
2005, I graduated.
And indeed, I did a
little bit of work
in this area of single
molecule fluorescence,
and I was basically
unsuccessful.
Even just doing this kind
of an in vitro setting.
My lab is [INAUDIBLE],
we did primarily
single molecule manipulation.
We were playing with the
single molecule fluorescence .
And eventually, people in
the lab got it to work.
But I would say that my foray
into it was maybe unsuccessful.
So I had a very healthy
respect for the challenges
that are involved in doing
single molecule fluorescence.
And the thought of doing this
in live cells was very scary.
And I'd say that
many of us thought
it was not going to work.
And indeed, this
project was one--
and the general goal of
studying a single molecule
dynamics in living
cells, is something
that's Sunney's group had
been working on, I think,
for many years.
And it indeed was very hard.
But then there were
these two papers
they came out, both from
Sunnye's lab actually.
And they came out both, i
think, in January of 2006,
one in science, one in
Nature, demonstrating
not one way of doing
this, but rather two
ways of getting single molecule
dynamics inside living cells.
So today, obviously, we're
going to be primarily talking
about this paper by [INAUDIBLE].
But if you're interested
in these things,
I encourage you to check
out [INAUDIBLE] paper, which
also published, [INAUDIBLE],
at the same time.
And that was based on a
microfluidic assay, where
instead of doing
the single molecule
fluorescence within
cells, instead by trapping
the cells in small
volumes, and then using
more traditional enzymatic
assays, such as this beta
[INAUDIBLE] assay,
enclosed in a small volume,
it's almost possible to
study, once again, these sort
of busting dynamics in E. coli.
And also they did it in
yeast, and demonstrated
that it's kind of a
generally practical assay.
So if you're interested
in those papers,
I encourage you to check it out.
But for me, this was really
an eye-opening thing.
So I graduated with my
Ph.D. in December of 2005,
and then I went to a conference
in Cambridge, England,
where where Sunney
presented this work.
And I think that it really blew
many of our minds, this idea
that you could start to get this
sort of data within live cells.
And indeed, Sunney's group
over the next five years
did a whole series
of what I'd consider
to be beautiful studies,
probing, for example,
the dynamics of this [INAUDIBLE]
repressor binding, unbindings
onto this promoter,
the search process.
Yeah.
A whole slew of, I think,
really beautiful things.
So we're not going
to have the chance
to go over all those
papers in this class,
but I encourage you
to look at them.
Can somebody say what
the primary challenge
is with doing single
molecule fluorescence
in these live cells?
So why is it that
I did not think
that this was going to work?
And now, you're going to
have to give an argument that
ends up not being true.
But why is it that this is
such a hard thing to do.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
laser at the cell
but you can't kill the cell?
PROFESSOR: Right.
OK.
So one is that there's
laser, the cell, and then
there's a big question mark.
Is this going to be OK?
And indeed, we certainly
know that at one limit,
it's not going to be OK.
If you take the lasers at
Los Alamos National Lab,
you can vaporize the cell.
So it's certainly enough
power, and the cell's
going to be dead for sure.
And so the question
is maybe, oh,
can you dial down the
laser power enough to get--
and indeed, this is something
that they talk about,
their strategy in this paper.
Other challenges, problems?
AUDIENCE: Many molecules.
PROFESSOR: Right. so the
principle of many molecules.
So we have to figure out
some way of separating them,
either temporarily or spatially.
Indeed in this paper,
they actually do both.
We say many molecules.
And of course, we have to
decide what we mean by this.
Because ultimately,
we're interested in doing
single molecule measurements.
But then, of course, of the
plural of single is many.
How many is too many for
us to study, and so forth?
The question here is maybe
like, how to separate, right?
What are other
challenges in this?
AUDIENCE: Diffusion.
PROFESSOR: Right.
There's diffusion.
So we're going to talk
more about this, for sure.
Well, actually, all
of these things,
we're going to talk about.
Diffusion.
And why is this a
problem, though?
Right.
So it's diffusion is maybe fast.
And so this is going to end
up being relevant for kind
of signal to noise reasons.
So what's the signal
and what's the noise?
AUDIENCE: Autofluorescence.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So there's autofluorescence.
So in particular, this noise
is autofluorescence from what?
AUDIENCE: From the cell.
PROFESSOR: From the cell.
Right.
And what's the signal,
just to be clear here?
AUDIENCE: Photons
from [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So it's photons from, in this
case, the GFP-like molecule.
Yeah?
So we want to do single
molecule measurements.
We want to be able
to measure or detect
the fluorescence coming
from this single fluorescent
protein.
Now the question is, if
it's a single molecule,
does that mean that
it's going to send out
just a single photon?
No.
Maybe they come out
as single photons.
But we can detect them.
Now the challenge in,
in some ways surprising,
is not that the number
of photons is so small.
Does anybody have any
rough sense of maybe
how many photons are we
collecting from each of these?
AUDIENCE: Many thousands.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
I'd say many thousands.
In particular-- so we'll
say many thousands.
It could be even 10 to
the 4 per second or so.
It depends on the
laser intensity.
Many thousands of
photons collected.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: That's
before [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
That's right.
And indeed, the stronger
the intensity of the laser
light that you illuminate
with, the faster you're
going to collect the
photons, but in general, it
won't increase the total number
of photons that you collect.
So in these sorts
of situations, you
might get, say-- we'll say
10 to the 4, plus or minus
in order of magnitude,
photons per second.
And they might
last for, depending
on how-- for 30 seconds or so.
And of course, we'll look at the
actual numbers in this paper.
But in many of
these situations--
times 10 to 100 seconds.
In this case, it
actually bleached faster.
Right.
But we'll see.
Well, you might be
able to get also--
if you use organic
dyes and other-- right.
But this gives you some
sense of that there's
a fair number of photons
that you could, in principle,
collect from a single molecule.
Now, of course, you
might be worried, well,
these are the photons that
you shine on your camera.
But then your camera
won't pick up all of them.
The way that we
think about this is
by what's known as the
quantum efficiency.
Quantum efficiency
tells us basically
this is the fraction
of photons detected.
But with modern cameras,
actually, this thing
is approximately one.
So it's 0.9 maybe
with modern cameras,
which is for our
purposes, basically one.
Which means that you
can detect, actually,
the majority of the photons
that are hitting your camera.
From that standpoint,
the number of photons
is not actually the problem.
You can collect many
thousands of photons.
So the problem is really
detecting that signal
over the background signal.
Over the autofluorescence
of the cell.
And indeed, if you look
at the figure, figure one,
you can very clearly see the
autofluorescence of the cell.
So the fluorescence
where there's the cell
is indeed much larger than
where there's no cell.
The autofluorescence is, I'd
say, the primary challenge
here.
Of course, there are
many, many others.
Right.
So this is potentially
a big problem.
And in order to get
around that, there
are all these other
strategies that the author's
going to implement.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What is
the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So many things are
weakly fluorescent,
I think is the short answer.
And this also depends
upon, for example, cells
are more autofluorescent if
you grow them in a rich media
than in minimal media, for
some mysterious reason.
Yeah.
But it's really just that
there are many things that
are weakly fluorescent.
And it's just there are a
lot of molecules in a cell.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, right.
In the case that you put
in a fluorescent protein
or a fluorescent
dye, then it has
rather well-defined absorption
and emission spectra.
And each individual
absorber emitter
indeed has a well-defined
absorption emission profile.
But then in the cell, there
are just many, many, many
of them, which means
that there's rather
what you want to
call an absorption
of broadband emission.
So indeed, in some wavelengths,
it's worse than in others.
But it's not that you get
well-defined peaks the way
you do for a single
kind of [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I guess I was
just wondering [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
And indeed, in this case,
they're exciting with a laser.
So at least on the
excitation, it's
as precise as you can hope for.
And indeed, on the emission
they will use a filter.
So they're not going
to be absorbed.
It's probably a few
tens of nanometers
that they're looking at.
So in that sense, they
are filtering out,
but still, there is
autofluorescence.
All right.
Now getting at this question
of the single molecule
fluorescence, the
limitations, diffusion,
and so forth, it's
always valuable to have
a sense of scale in anything
that you're ever doing.
So just let's wake up
by reminding ourselves,
how big is a protein?
Right.
So, typical protein.
Typical protein.
And for now, we'll say e.g.
For example, GFP or whatever.
All right.
We're not going to give you very
much time to think about this.
But I just want to
make sure that we all
keep track of senses
of scale in the world.
Ready.
Three, two, one.
All right.
So we've got some B's, C's, D's.
Wow.
We got a lot of surprisingly
wide wide range, actually.
[LAUGHING] OK.
Well, we also have the mirror
image problem over here.
OK, right.
So, indeed, I'll say this
is a typical protein size.
So, it's a few nanometers.
Depending on, there are
some that get longer,
especially if you're
thinking about a long--
there are some structural--
well, you know.
Of course, if you're talking
about filaments, they can be--
but if you're talking about
a typical globular protein,
it's a few nanometers
in diameter.
The question is,
let's say that this is
a fluorescent protein, or GFP.
And now what we do
is we look at it.
And we're going to get
some fluorescent spot.
So this is plotting
the intensity
as a function of position.
Right?
So this is the intensity I
is a function of position X.
Now the question
is, what is going
to be the size of the spot?
We conveniently have some
size scales up on the board.
I'll let us think about
this for eight seconds.
All right.
Ready.
Three, two, one.
OK.
We have a majority
of the group that
is saying that indeed,
it's going to be D.
So this is what's known as
a diffraction limited spot.
And this is a fundamental
physics limitation,
that if you are imaging
something with light that
is of some wavelength,
lambda, this
is of order lambda over 2-- it
depends on numerical aperture
or projective and so forth.
But you know.
So order of lambda.
A little bit less maybe.
And indeed, the
wavelength of the light
that's being used
here is-- they're
exciting with 500 something.
And then let me just-- 514.
OK.
So indeed, what happens
is that we shine in light.
So this is the lambda
incident that is 514.
Now, there's going to be some
GFP that looks like this.
And then, we're going to
get out lambda emission.
All right.
Question, is the emitted
light going to be equal?
Is the wavelength going
to be 514 nanometers?
Yes or no?
Ready?
Three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
Lambda emission.
Is it going to be greater than
or less than lambda incident?
Ready?
Three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: Greater than.
PROFESSOR: Greater than.
So this thing is
greater than 514.
Now, if you just have scattering
off something-- so let's
say that we had a
gold particle, and we
shine-- what's going
to be the relationship
between lamba incident
and lambda emission?
Is it possible to have the
same wavelength come out
as you put in of some object?
Yes.
If you just have
something, a mirror,
you can get back--
so it is possible.
But in general, there's
going to be some dissipation.
It's a question of
how much and so forth.
But certainly for something
like fluorescence,
you have a higher
energy photon, and you
have a photon that's emitted.
And of course, energy
goes as 1 over lambda.
Now, this is useful
because you can actually
spectrally separate things.
I just want to
highlight, though,
that if this separation
is of order 300
nanometers and our protein
is-- that [INAUDIBLE] our GFP.
Nicely drawn.
Not even quite to scale.
To scale, it's
actually even smaller.
It's a factor of 100 in size.
This thing is only 3 nanometers
in size, 300 nanometers wide.
Now, it's important to be
clear about what this means,
this diffraction limited spot.
The first thing to note
is that what it means
is that if you have two
proteins-- so for example,
I add another one
over here-- that it's
going to be very hard to
tell that we have those two
proteins next to each other.
Because the resulting
fluorescence
pattern will look
essentially the same.
Will it be exactly the same?
What's going to change?
The intensity.
The intensity, you expect
to go up by a factor of two,
absent some interaction between.
You can, in principle,
get interactions there.
But let's for now assume
that there's no interaction.
Right.
Then the intensity wouldn't need
to go up by a factor of two.
But unless you're very careful
about all of your optics
and so forth, it's
actually a challenge
to use this intensity alone
to distinguish these things.
It's only-- so the statement
with a diffraction--
you need these two proteins
to be separated by something
like lambda over
2 in order for you
to start to see the separation.
Right.
Because then you have
something that looks like this.
Something that looks like this.
And then the sum of those
two, indeed-- so you say,
all right, well, it looks like
there are two molecules there.
Now, I just want
to-- and the notion
of a lot of these so-called
super resolution techniques
is figuring out a way to
distinguish these things,
and we'll maybe say something
about that in a moment.
But I just want to highlight
that if we come back
to the situation where we
have a single protein there.
Now the question is,
how accurately can we
tell where that protein
is, if we know that there's
just a single protein there?
Now in particular,
this size of the spot
is telling us something,
but it might not
be quite as strong
of a limitation
as it appears at first glance.
And that's because in
this case, well maybe
I'll bring it back, what
we see is a big spot.
300 nanometers, kind of wide.
But if we see this and we know
it's just a single protein
there, I mean, could the
protein be over here?
No.
If the protein where
over here, then the spot
would be over there right.
So actually, even though
the size of the spot
is 300 nanometers,
in principle, if you
want to know where
that protein is,
if you know there's
just a single protein,
well, in that case what
you want to know is,
where's the center
of that distribution?
And that problem, well, the
width of the distribution
is relevant.
But there's something else
that's also very relevant.
And quite generally, if you
measure some quantity n times,
and you want to know-- so you're
measuring the height of min
entering the army-- if you
want to know the mean, what
is it that determines your
uncertainty around the mean?
Right.
There's the sample size.
Now, does the width of
the distribution enter?
Yeah.
So in general, your
uncertainty in the mean
is going to go with the width
of the distribution, sigma
of whatever, divided by--
what do I put down here?
Root of N, where N is the
number of samples that we take.
What this is saying
is that as we sample
this distribution
more and more, does
the standard deviation of the
distribution, does it go to 0?
No.
These are all
trivial statements,
but I can't tell
you how many times
I see this getting confused.
OK.
So if you measure
many, many, many times,
you get a very
beautiful distribution.
Right.
The width of this
region of the sigma,
that you get very accurately.
It's true also that your
uncertainty in the width, that
actually does go to 0.
But the width of it, the
width doesn't go to 0.
The width of the distribution.
But your uncertainty in the
mean, that goes down as 1
over root of N. And what is N in
the case our detection business
here?
The number of photons.
Right?
Now, of course, in
the actual experiment,
we don't get precisely
this distribution.
Instead, it's kind of
sort of quantized somehow
spatially, because
we're actually
detecting it on a CCD chip.
All right.
So you can go and do the
math, figure out everything.
But actually, that's
not as much a limitation
as you might have expected.
In many cases, the pixel
size on the image plane
is actually something
like 100 nanometers.
So this distribution
that measure,
although in principle it looks
like this, what you actually
measure is something that
looks like-- well, maybe I
should-- something like that.
Right.
Because you have discrete
pixels on the CCD.
And it feels that that should
just kind of totally screw you.
But if you go and
do the math, you
find it's not as bad
as you might expect.
So broadly, you do get
essentially something
that goes as 1
over the root of N,
where N is the
number of photons.
And if you collect 10 to the
4 photons, that actually,
it's a lot of photons.
So if we want to
know the uncertainty
in the center of our
distribution, well, this thing,
we might have something that's
of order 300 nanometers here.
We take the square
root of 10 to the 4.
All right.
So we get to divide
by something like 100.
And these are all
very rough numbers.
But the point is
that we can get down
to nanometer resolution in
terms of the uncertainty
that which we know the
mean of that distribution.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yeah.
Right.
So again, it's surprising.
The thing is that
even with just two,
in principle, we can
be very sensitive.
Right?
I mean, actually,
sometimes people actually
do just put it on like
quadrant photo detector, where
you really only get
essentially binary information.
But even with just two, if I say
OK, well, it looks like this,
or if it looks a
little bit like that,
if there's no error in
our measurements there,
then you can actually get
that location very well.
Yeah.
It's surprising.
I'm not going to like.
Yeah, but even with
this quantization
of some sort that's
due to the CCD, city
you can still get down
to nanometer resolution.
Your resolution is worse than
it would be if you knew actually
exactly where each
photon was hitting,
but it's not very
sensitive, actually.
And indeed, in the
presence of-- and
this is a highly
technical comment.
But in the presence of
read noise and other kinds
of noise in the CCD,
actually, in many cases,
it's actually better to
have somewhat larger pixels,
again, than you would expect.
So these balancing
many different things.
People have thought
carefully about this stuff.
But in the end, 100 nanometer
pixel is actually fine.
And just to be clear, it's 100
nanometers at the sample plane.
So it's typically
of order 10 microns
size on the camera itself.
So the physical size of each of
the pixels on the cameras, 10
microns within a factor
of 2, between 5 and 20,
but then you get 100x
typically magnification
at the sample point.
So to be clear, 10
microns divided by 100
is 100 nanometers.
Is everybody following?
OK I don't want to-- all right.
The key thing--
three, you can ignore.
But the key thing
to notice here is
this thing that's here, which
is nanometer resolution.
And it's been known for decades
that this is, in principle,
possible and so forth.
But I think that within the
realm of single molecule
biophysics, it was really
popularized in some very nice
papers by Ahmet Yildiz,
et al, where they attached
single molecules onto the
heads of various motors
as they were walking
along tracks, and showing
that these motors were
walking kind of like this,
by catching fluorophores here,
and then you could really just
see it, see them walking it.
Any questions about
why it's in principle
possible to get nanometer
resolution in this process?
AUDIENCE: Doesn't this
assume that the protein
is 100% static?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah, indeed.
Right now, I'm assuming
that this thing is constant.
And the question is like, how
much movement is a problem?
And so then you
have to-- you know.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So indeed, often, you're
trading off spatial resolution
for temporal resolution.
And also, the intensity of
your laser, and so forth.
But in these sort
of experiments,
I think that what they
did is they slowed down
the motors quite a lot.
So it was limiting ATP.
So indeed, the motors
in those experiments,
I think they were taking
steps of order every second
or 10 seconds.
I mean, it was as slow as
you can go, and still, yes.
And then at each
location, I think
they were collecting 10 to the
4 or a few 10 to the 4 photons.
And incidentally
in this case, these
are the photons that
are being collected.
And typically, you
would only be collecting
10%, 15% of the photons.
Because the photons are actually
being emitted everywhere.
But you only collect the ones
that go back to your objective.
All right.
I just want to make one comment
about the super resolution
techniques that
have been spreading.
So the question
here is, well, let's
say that you have two
proteins next to each other.
What can you do?
Now, the basic idea of all these
super resolution techniques
is that if we know that we have
a signal for only one protein,
then we can actually
figure out where it is.
So what you need
to do is figure out
a way so you just have
one at a time emitting.
So there are various
schemes to make it
so that these proteins
can either turn on or off.
Now, what you can do is
if just one turns on,
you got some photons,
you say OK, this protein
goes over here.
Then if later, this other
protein becomes fluorescent,
now you can figure
out where that is.
And so you do this basic
super resolution localization
multiple times, and then you
can identify where things are.
Yeah.
So all the microscopy
guys really
like to have fun acronyms.
So these guys, when they did
it, they called it FIONA.
So this is-- is it DreamWorks?
Or this is where the green
ogre like that and then
the red head?
AUDIENCE: Shrek.
PROFESSOR: Shrek?
All right.
So Shrek.
And so Fiona was the redhead.
And this stands for
fluorescent imaging
with 1 nanometer accuracy.
And then indeed, a
group at UCSF then
developed SHREK, which is
simultaneous high resolution
imaging-- something.
OK.
I can't remember how it ended.
But, yeah.
So the super
resolution techniques,
they call them-- so Xiaowei
Zhuang at Harvard called
hers STORM, stochastic
reconstruction
of something or another.
So this is the Zhuang method.
And then Eric Betzig
called his PALM, which
stood still for something else.
I don't know.
But in particular,
Betzig-- there's
a long history of the
hard core microscopists,
somehow like, developing their
techniques in their garages.
I don't know what it
is, but there have
been a number of these cases.
And Betzig I think
was one of them.
Now he's at Janelia
Farm, HHMI, and has
been developing all sorts of
advanced microscopy techniques.
So I think that that
[INAUDIBLE] did not
develop hers in the garage.
But um--
AUDIENCE: And they're all
based on the same principle--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's all about temporal.
It's a question of
how you're getting
them to turn on and off.
AUDIENCE: It sounds like
[INAUDIBLE] acronyms.
PROFESSOR: Oh do they also have?
AUDIENCE: ROSY, COZY, NOSY.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Right, right.
For the different
sequences or something?
Yeah, yeah.
All of these acronyms,
maybe I just never came up
with a good one, so then I--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Indeed.
I always like when somebody
uses acronyms that I don't know,
I always like to say, oh,
all these TLAs are tricky,
or whatever.
And then I say, it's
three letter acronym.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHING]
PROFESSOR: I very much like
self-referential humor.
OK.
So that's the idea of the
super resolution techniques.
Any questions about
that before we
kind of get back
actually to the paper?
OK.
Now in this whole discussion,
as was pointed out,
we've been assuming that the
protein is not moving around
during our imaging time.
So one of the major challenges
of doing this whole business
in live cells is
not only is there
a lot of autofluorescence,
but in addition, you
can't necessarily
wait 10 seconds
to localize where this thing
is, because it will have
moved somewhere else right.
And in particular,
diffusion is a problem.
Can somebody remind
us what the authors
did in order to get around
the diffusion problems?
I'm sorry what was it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: They attached
it to the membrane.
And why does that help?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's perfect.
Proteins diffuse slower.
And I think depending
on the organism,
there's more or less
diffusion and so forth right.
But what they did is they
anchored to the membrane
to reduce diffusion.
I'll just say it
reduces diffusion.
And indeed, just from a back
of the envelope calculation,
you can convince yourself
that you probably
are going to need to do this.
So in particular, let's
ask-- in this paper,
actually, they image the
fluorophore for 0.1 seconds,
right?
Does that sound right?
So the image collected, so
delta t is equal to 0.1 sets.
So the question is, how far
will a protein typically
diffuse in 0.1 seconds?
Well, this is why we have
diffusion calculations.
Right.
First of all, the
diffusion coefficient,
we're going to talk more about
diffusion in a few weeks.
But you should also
in principal be
able to calculate
how these things go.
So in general,
this is going to be
a kT over some gamma, which
tells us how hard-- so kT is
thermal energy.
OK.
So, thermal.
And at room temperature
kT is around 4.1
piconewton nanometers
in some unit.
There are many different
ways you can write that.
Whereas gamma tells us just how
hard it is to push something.
In particular, if you
push them with some force,
it will move with some velocity.
Now is this consistent
with freshman mechanics?
No.
It's not.
OK.
Is that a problem?
So why is it that
I'm writing this?
AUDIENCE: Solvents exerting
a force [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So solvents exerting a force.
That's true.
But in the case of
freshman mechanics,
when we're pushing
blocks, it's also true
that the other things
are exerting forces.
The tables.
But we still write
down F is equal to MA.
So it's not just that other
things are exerting forces.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: They're
always in a continuum?
PROFESSOR: Always
in a continuum.
AUDIENCE: They're always
surrounded by [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Yeah.
It's always surrounded--
but I'm actually
surrounded by fluid now too.
You know, you can wave
your arms and feel it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, right.
So it comes down
to the viscosity.
Indeed, this whole thing about
being a low Reynolds number,
we're going to talk about
this in much more detail
in a few weeks, when we think
about how bacteria swim,
and so forth.
But I just want to
mention that this
is because we're at this
low Reynolds number, where
the so-called inertial forces,
like momentum are negligible.
Inertia forces are negligible.
So then it's really,
this is in some ways
more like Aristotelian
physics, but it ends up
being true for small
objects in viscous liquids.
And indeed, this thing
it scales as the radius.
So in principle, we can
actually calculate roughly
how the diffusion coefficient
is going to behave
as a function of size.
The object and so forth.
But I'll just tell you that
for a protein size object
in the cell, you
might get something
like 10 micron
squared per second.
Now, already just
from units, you
can see how the kind of
typical diffusion distance
has to scale with time.
And in particular,
you're going to get
that the typical
kind of distance
that you go in a
typical distance-- we'll
say square root, because it's
the square root of 2 times D
times time.
So you can see if you
multiply the time by the D,
then you end up with
a micron squared,
so you have to take a square
root to get something that's
a characteristic distance.
And indeed, this is the
kind of math that I can do.
So this is an order one micron.
And how big is an E. coli cell?
AUDIENCE: One micron?
PROFESSOR: One micron,
roughly, right?
So it might be a
couple microns long.
A bit less than a
micron in width.
And what this is saying
is that 0.1 seconds, which
is our exposure
time on our camera,
you would expect
something like GFP
to diffuse around
roughly the cell volume.
And maybe not the entire one,
but a fair fraction of it.
What this is saying is
that the diffusion really
would be a problem, even with
this relatively short exposure
time.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So this is assuming
that the cytoplasm has
a viscosity that's maybe
an order of magnitude
larger than water.
And that's just
because the inside
is chock full of
proteins and so forth.
Now, there's a lot
of discussion of what
the mechanism is of diffusion
and transport inside cells.
It may depend on the size.
It's a very complicated area.
But for our purposes,
this is a reasonable way
to think about it.
But indeed, the viscosity
of the cytoplasm, you'd
expect to be significantly more
than the viscosity of water.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
lower the [INAUDIBLE] time?
PROFESSOR: Lower the?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Like two orders of
magnitude instead of one?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So in principle, we could.
There are technical
issues on various sides.
So of course, you have to say,
oh well, a typical camera, just
the shutter of
opening, shutting,
that actually has some limit.
But you can get around that
using kind of strob-- you know,
there are fancy
things you can do.
But there's just a more
fundamental thing here,
which is-- so this is
already 100 milliseconds.
If you go down to like
say, 1 millisecond,
then it's true that
the protein won't
be able to diffuse very
far, but then you also just
don't collect any photons.
The number of photons
you collect scales
linearly with the time, right?
So at some point, it's
just that you really
don't get very many photons.
And then again, you
have this extra problem
of distinguishing
the fluorescence
from the autofluorescence.
And I just want to maybe
mention one more thing.
In Figure 1, you
can actually see
how big the fluorescence
intensity of this Venus protein
is, as compared to
the autofluorescence.
And you see that if you decrease
that exposure time by even one
order of magnitude, you
wouldn't be able to see them
over the background.
Right?
And that's true, even
though they won't
have had a chance to diffuse.
It's just that you don't
have enough signal.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh.
Right.
So you can also
increase the intensity.
Yeah, that's right.
And there is some
limit to how much
you can increase the
intensity of the laser,
just because there
is some cycling
time of the protein in
terms of, you excite it,
and then it takes some time
before it's going to emit.
So that actually sets
a fundamental limit.
Yeah, I don't know enough
about the details of this
in the sense of whether maybe it
would've been possible for them
to try to adjust these
various parameters
to do it in some other way.
But these are all the
things you have to consider.
Question?
OK.
So what we have now
is some sense-- OK,
we need to maybe anchor
into the membrane
to reduce the diffusion.
All right.
So they did that.
And we'll maybe say something
more about this anchoring
process in a moment.
But first, I want to
make sure that we're
all on the same page
in understanding
their arguments for why this is
a single molecule that they're
looking at.
Can somebody remind us
their primary evidence
that this is a single molecule?
So question is, a molecule ,
we'll say single fluorophore,
just to-- question mark.
How do we know?
AUDIENCE: The
intensity drops off.
PROFESSOR: Right.
The intensity
drops off suddenly.
So if you look at the intensity
as a function of time,
what you see is that it
looks like, and then.
So it's actually more noise,
but this is just to-- now
this is what it looks like
for a single molecule,
but we should also be
clear of what it would look
like if it were many molecules.
So this is if it's
a single molecule.
And this is what we
call a bleach event.
And so the molecule dies
for one reason or another.
So it goes, some oxygen
reaction, something.
Now the question is,
what happens if it
said there are many molecules?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Now, what we want
to do is imaginn--
let's say that we
shined light on a bead
containing
fluorescence, containing
fluorescent molecules.
So I'm going to give
us some options.
It could be many molecules.
OK.
We could.
All right.
I'll give you a
choice those three.
AUDIENCE: So we're
talking about [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
I'm asking if instead-- what
happens in the microscope
is you see a spot.
And the spot is always huge.
Right?
300 nanometers.
So there could be one molecule
there, or there could be 100.
You could fit 1,000 in there.
No problem.
Right?
10 by 10 by 10 molecules?
That still is only
30 nanometers.
That's still much smaller
than defraction limited spot.
So of course, if
you see something,
and the spot is 10
microns in width,
you'd be pretty confident
that either your optics suck,
or you're looking
at many molecules.
But if you see
diffraction limited spot,
then it's not so obvious.
And so the question
is, if you plot
the intensity of a
diffraction limited spot
as a function of
time, how do you know
that it's a single molecule?
They claim, oh well,
it's because of this.
But it's always
good to be clear.
What would it look like if it
were not a single molecule,
but instead it were a collection
of molecules> Let's go ahead
and vote.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
So we have a fair number
of different responses.
It seems to be a split across
the room is the only problem.
So I'm not going to
have you discuss,
because I think your neighbors
typically agree with you.
But in this case,
it's going to be
C. And this, it was an
attempt of mine of drawing--
what is it?
Exponential distribution.
So you'll see exponential decay.
So this is typical
of processes where
something is happening at
a constant rate over time,
and then you're seeing
this thing go away.
So this could be, for
example, radioactivity
is the classic thing
we always talk.
These are random events.
We thought the radiation
coming off of some source
is a function of time that's
going to decay exponentially.
Similarly here, now
this is-- again,
intensity is a function of time.
In the case of
many molecules, we
get this thing that look
like C. Now, there's
going to be some time scale
here which is telling us
about the typical time for this
bleach event, which we're told
is what?
250 milliseconds.
And indeed, this is
telling us, actually,
that they're already
illuminating these guys
at pretty high intensity.
Because 250 milliseconds
is not that long.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is it
really a function
common photons [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: It's not
really a function of the--
it ends up being a function
of the number of photons that
are emitted, but that's
basically because you're
in kind of some ground state.
You excite up to
this other state.
And then, you get this
relaxation to a lower state.
So this is the energy
of the absorbed photon.
This is the energy of
the emitted photon.
The idea is that each time you
go around this cycle, that's
one emission cycle,
there's some probability
that's small-- 1 in 10 to the
5, or something like that--
that it reacts with
oxygen, or something that
causes it to go to the start.
And it's in principle,
irreversible state.
Of course, the dynamics of these
things can be more complicated,
but that's the [INAUDIBLE]
way of thinking about it.
What that means is that
that's more or less
a constant number of photons
that you're going to get out.
There are many cases where
this approximation fails.
This single step bleaching is
kind of a classic signature
of the fact that
you're looking at
a single fluorescent molecule.
Now, there are
secondary arguments
for why this is a
single [INAUDIBLE] Venus
they're looking at was what?
What was their
supporting evidence?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
The intensity matched what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So what they said
is, well, all right.
This intensity matched what
they measured on a slide.
Just the molecule.
But I'd say this really is, I
would say, supporting evidence,
because the intensity
of the fluorescence
can just be different in
different environments.
I think that this is kind of
thing that it's-- there are
many ways that this can fail.
Right, so I think that
in general, we consider
this to be the gold standard.
All right.
Now in their experimental
setup, there's
something that's,
I think, very nice
that they do, which is,
if you look at the-- now
this is the we'll say,
laser illumination.
Here, this is kind of
on, and this is off.
What they do is every three
minutes, they illuminate.
And then, this is not to scale.
This was 1.2 seconds.
So we might want to even--
there's a separation in there.
So they illuminate
for 1.2 seconds,
and they collect the light
for the first 0.1 seconds.
This is the period where
they collect for 0.1.
Can somebody tell us why they
might possibly want to do this?
Shine more light on the
sample than they need to?
They're not going to
analyze that data.
So this is an intentional
bleaching step.
So this part here is to bleach.
And we'll see that this is
actually essential for the way
that they're
collecting their data.
Given everything
that we've just said,
you should be able to tell me
what fraction of the molecules
will not be bleached.
That survive bleaching.
Survive the so-called
bleaching step.
You can ignore my writing.
You should be able to
think about it on your own.
I'll go ahead, and I'll give you
30 seconds to think about this.
And I think all
of the information
that you need is in principle
written up on the board.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
I'm assuming that they
start out being fluorescent.
Now over time, we're
illuminating them
with this laser light.
So eventually, they will bleach.
But perhaps some of them have
survived for that entire 1.2
seconds.
So if you looked at it
after this bleaching step,
it would still be fluorescent.
Maybe another 30
seconds, because--
Do you need more time?
Let me see where we
are, just so that we
can get a sense of things.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
All right.
Great.
We're roughly
uniformly distributed
between-- all right.
Perfect.
So this is an opportunity
to turn to your neighbor
and discuss.
You should, even with
back of the envelope
calculations in your head, be
able to get roughly where this.
But you're also welcome, if
you want, to double check.
Pull out your iPhone.
You can use the
Google calculator.
I give you just a minute or
two to turn to a neighbor.
You should certainly be
able to find somebody
that disagrees with you.
[STUDENT CHATTER]
PROFESSOR: Why don't we
go ahead and reconvene?
It's OK if you're still
kind of confused by this.
I've partly doing
this to encourage
you to review your
probability distributions,
because we are going to
dive into them rather
strongly over the next week.
And so it's good--
if you can't quite
remember how these
are going to work,
it's good to start
reviewing now.
All right.
Can I just see where we are?
Ready?
Three, two, one.
OK.
So we have some B's and C's.
All right.
I'm pretty confident
it's B, although I'm
a little bit worried now.
All right, so what's
going to happen?
So basically, the probability
that this thing survives
as a function of
time is the same
as, essentially, the decay
and the overall intensity
fluorescence for many
molecules over time.
Because this plot
here is really a plot
of the fraction of
the molecules that
have survived as a
function of time.
Right.
So indeed, the
probability of survival
for an exponential process like
this is a function of time, t,
is going to be equal
to e to the minus t
over some constant [INAUDIBLE].
And what is t in tau?
Well, t is this
time 1.2 seconds.
So we have e to the-- we'll
write it like an exponent.
So now we have a minus.
We have 1.2 seconds divided by
the lifetime in this condition,
we're told is 250 milliseconds.
So we can write 0.25 seconds.
So this is approximately
e to the minus 5,
which indeed, is equal to
what I thought is 0.8%.
So it's around 1%,
Are there any questions about
this logic or this calculation?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, no, no.
Sorry, sorry.
No, no.
Bleaching, this is a result
of chemical inactivation
of the fluorescent protein
that is kind of induced
by being in this excited state.
So the idea is that if
you're shining light
on this fluorescent
protein, then
it's going to bleach at a rate
that is kind of-- distribution
of say, lifetime's going to
be exponential with a time
constant of 250 milliseconds.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
That's right.
But it's a one-step
process though.
That's what we see here.
It's not that that
individual protein
is getting worse and
worse as it's being used.
But it's really just
that there's some rate
that it-- some
probability, of course,
time that it cycles that it is,
we'll say for now, irreversibly
inactivated.
There are also all these
so-called blinking events,
where fluorescent molecules
can kind of temporarily
go into a non-fluorescent
state, and then they return,
but right now, we're talking
about these irreversible steps.
Are there any other questions
about what I mean by bleaching,
or this calculation?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So my claim
is that 0.8% is very
close, is approximately 1%.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, sorry.
I did something funny here.
Yeah, yeah.
So it's useful to just kind of
go through these calculations.
And actually, I think that
in going through them,
you kind of really get
to get a sense of why
they design their
experiments the way they did
and everything.
So the idea is that what they're
doing here every three minutes,
they're looking at the
cells, and they're asking,
is there are a protein, or
maybe more than one here?
And then they try to kill all
those fluorescent proteins.
And then they look again
three minutes later.
Are there any new
proteins that were made.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
You can't see it [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
You don't--
AUDIENCE: Do you calibrate
the intensity [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So what they're
really doing is they're asking,
how many spots do I see?
So in that experiment,
they don't know
that it was a single molecule.
Although I think that in many--
AUDIENCE: Then why do they
talk about this [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, that's
how they checked to make
sure it was a single molecule.
Although I think that
actually, in principle here,
I think they actually maybe
do continue to look at them.
That's not part
of their analysis.
So for many of the
case, they actually
do see that this molecule is
here, and then it bleaches,
and a different molecule
was here, and it bleached.
But what they're really
asking is at the beginning,
how many fluorescent
proteins did I see?
And I think the camera actually
maybe was collecting still
during that bleaching step.
It's just that it wasn't
kind of part of it.
Their analysis is in some ways
really just based on this.
Or in other experiments,
you can go look
to confirm that it
bleaches single step here.
OK.
So we spent a long time talking
like the general idea of how
to design these
experiments and so forth.
I'm not going to say very
much about the design
of the experiments, except
that they did a number things.
They used this
Venus protein that
has a faster maturation
than traditional GFP.
They also targeted
it to the membrane,
not by putting Venus
into the membrane-- that
would be tricky, I
think-- but rather
by attaching the Venus protein
to another protein that
is put in the membrane.
And indeed, this TSR
membrane protein,
we're going to be
talking about it
in a couple of weeks
when we're discussing
the chemotaxis network that is
in E. coli for how E. coli find
food and so forth.
I think that in reading these
papers, it's interesting.
Sometimes, authors make
kind of a side comment
that just illuminates kind of
how difficult everything was.
And I think that they
had a nice one in here,
where they said that they were
checking with TSR to make sure
that the behavior of the
TSR Venus and just Venus
were similar in terms of
the amount of fluorescence.
And then, they say,
no notable difference
was observed, indicating that
the introduction of the TSR
sequence does not change the
yield of Venus production,
which is not the case for
many other membrane targeting
sequences that we tested.
So this is like, a little
add-on onto the sentence
that is like, I mean, six
months of somebody's life
was dedicated to
trying-- you can just
imagine all the over
coffee, their frustration.
They tried all of
these different things,
and they always got-- and for
an awful lot of these things,
I would have still been very
much interested in the study,
even if the addition of TSR
did change the kinetics.
Because I think that
still is very interesting.
But they really wanted
this to be just airtight,
or maybe the referees
need to be-- I don't know.
But you can tell that they
just went to a lot of work
to try to find the thing where
everything would be just right.
Now, once they kind of
described their setup,
they had this wonderful
paragraph, I think.
They say, oh, these proteins,
they're generating bursts,
and the number in
the bursts varies,
and there's spread,
and so forth.
And they very nicely
tell us, with this data,
we can ask four questions.
And they say, do these
gene expression bursts
occur randomly in time?
That's going to be yes.
How many mRNA new molecules
are responsible for each gene
expression burst under
the repressed conditions?
One.
What is the distribution of
the number of protein molecules
in each burst?
It's going to be
geometrically distributed.
And what is the origin
of the temporal spread
of the individual bursts?
And now, I think
that this is nice,
just to give a reader
a kind of like,
heads up of where we're heading.
And the origin of
the temporal spread
is actually-- they're arguing
is actually the Venus maturation
time.
So in that case, the
fact that there's
a finite time for
maturation of the Venus
ends up allowing them
to measure the bursts
in an interesting way.
Before we get into
the details of that,
though, I want to make sure
that we're all clear about what
they mean by a burst.
Because this is
something that is oddly--
it feels like it's the most
trivial statement ever.
But I think what we're going
to find is that there's
a lot of confusion about it.
This is a question,
how is it that you
go from the data to the
quantities that they plot
and that they're interested in?
We want to get a sense of
how many proteins are made
in each one of these bursts?
And so they have
in Figure 3B, they
plot the number of protein
molecules produced.
Number of proteins produced.
It's a function of time.
And they have these things.
And This was a cell
division event.
And here they say, we have 2, 4.
And here at 25 minutes,
we have this thing here,
and it looks like.
And then this thing goes on.
And there's 50, we have
another, and so forth.
This is a zoom in of
Figure 3B, the top panel.
So what I want to know is, what
is the size of the first burst?
So you can either look at my
beautifully drawn illustration,
or you can look at the
paper in front of you.
So this is a paper analyzing
the size distribution
of protein bursts
observed in living cells.
Right?
That's the point of this paper.
Now, the question is, from
the data they're collecting,
we want to know what is the
size of the protein burst?
The first protein burst.
Now, there's no
calculation for you to do.
There's not much of one.
So I'm not going to
give you maybe anymore
time to figure this out.
So let's see where we are.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
All right.
So we got at least a
majority of the group
is saying that it's indeed 3.
Now, the issue here
is that the weight
of the experimental design is
working so that every three
minutes, what we're
asking is, how many Venus
molecules kind of folded in
that previous three minutes?
And then, any of
them that there are,
we count, and then we kill them.
And then, the next.
And indeed, what happened here
is that every three minutes,
they're asking this question.
No proteins.
And then here, they see one.
Now, that's not yet
a protein burst.
That's maybe a protein verse.
But it could be that we're in
the middle of a protein burst.
And indeed, what we see
is that the next time
point, the next three
minutes, we see, oh, actually,
now there's two new
proteins that were produced
in that next three minutes.
So indeed, this whole
thing is a protein burst.
So we got 1 plus 2.
So that was the calculation
I was referring to.
And so what they're
plotting is the distribution
of these different
protein burst sizes.
Now, this is a
small protein burst.
They see some that
get up to be 10, 15.
And that corresponds
to some of these cases,
where they see something
that looks, for example, more
like-- yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, right.
PROFESSOR: Yes, exactly.
And ultimately, first
of all, the number
of protein bursts
per cell cycle,
per hour in these
conditions, is of order one.
And then the width, the
time, of a protein burst
is five, seven minutes.
Something like that typically.
So this gives you a sense of how
frequently they will overlap.
And indeed, what you expect
from this is that 15% of them
are actually that they see
as one burst might actually
have been two though.
It's also worth
mentioning that-- right.
So what I just said is in the
model, where you know that it's
always just one mRNA that is
produced each time, what they
say is they think is that
the promoter is tightly
repressed by the Lac repressor.
Ever now and then, the
Lac repressor falls off,
and it's going to bind again.
But some fraction of that time,
when the repressor unbinds,
you get the RNA p
binding, and then you
get a transcription event.
And I think that in
general, it is just one
mRNA that is produced there.
So just a single RNA polymerase
bound, and made an mRNA.
But I'm sure that some
fraction of the time, it
was actually two that were
produced during that time.
And those would certainly
show up as one protein burst.
Right?
Because the lifetime of
the mRNAs in this situation
is of order what?
Yeah.
It was, I think, one and
a half minutes maybe?
It was short.
Yeah.
One and a half minutes.
What that means is that
on this time scale,
if there were two
mRNAs produced,
they would look
like the same mRNA.
But from this data
what they conclude
is that there's typically
only one mRNA produced
in each protein burst, and
there's not that many protein
bursts per hour of
the cell division,
so they won't overlap too much.
But it's going to
happen at some rate.
All right.
What they see is that the
distribution of the protein
bursts-- we said
it was roughly one
per cell division time, which
they found was 55 minutes here.
And they found that the number
of protein bursts per cell
cycle was distributed Poisson
So let me write
this down somewhere.
The number of protein
bursts per cell cycle.
So this was distributed
as a Poisson
with mean [INAUDIBLE]
lambda of around 1.
1.2.
They call this n cycle.
So I'll be consistent.
So this n cycle to the 1.2.
Now, you guys-- the
Poisson is a distribution
that we're going to be spending
a lot of time thinking about.
So the normal way
that we write it
is that if it's the probability
of observing some number n--
and this is a number n bursts
per cycle in this case, p of n.
We normally write
it as a function
of the mean lambda, where
it's lambda to the n over n
factorial.
And then for
normalization, we have
to write e to the
minus lambda here.
We're going to spend
a lot of time thinking
about the Poisson next class.
So I would say that if it's
been a while since you've
thought about probability
distributions, then
you should play via
textbook, Wikipedia, whatnot,
with the Poisson, the
exponential, the geometric,
and also the gamma
distributions.
Because we're going to be
using those in the next class.
Now, in this distribution,
what it basically
ends up being is that
sometimes, you see zero bursts.
Sometimes you see one.
Every now and then, you see two.
It's kind of what this means.
There's one other thing that
is, I think, a bit tricky often,
which is how they calculated
that it was typically
one mRNA that led to each
of these proteins bursts.
Can somebody remind us
kind of experimentally
what they had to do in
order to get at that?
The average RNA per cell, right.
Right, so they did this RT-PCR.
So what they did, they
reverse transcribed.
They converted
the mRNA into DNA,
and they amplified to get a
sense of how much mRNA there
was.
And from that, the formula,
when you first look at it,
it feels kind of mysterious,
or something like that.
But it's one of those
things that you just
have to keep track of
like, units and so forth.
So you can basically think
about the number of mRNA.
And this is indeed,
this is per cell.
But cell, this doesn't
have units, right?
But if we wanted the
expectation value,
the number of the mRNA
that's going to be per cell,
well, that's going to
be given by the number
of the mRNA per burst, times the
number of bursts per unit time.
So this is some rate
burst, and then also
times the lifetime of the mRNA.
Now in this formula, there's
also the added factor,
where they have like, the
time of the cell cycle.
But that's just
because this could
have been bursts per minute,
lifetime of mRNA minutes.
But then, if you want to
put in the extra term,
then you have to say, oh,
the cell cycle is 55 minutes.
So then you have to do
that conversion of time
into the proper units.
So that's what
ends up happening.
Are there any questions
about what happened here?
Now, what we're going to do
next lecture is kind of go
through a simplified
model of gene expression,
where there's just some
rate of mRNA formation, mRNA
degradation, the mRNA makes
protein, proteins get degraded.
And then in that model, we
want to try to understand
how everything is distributed.
And we're going to
relate that back
to some of the experimental
data in this paper.
In particular, for example,
this geometric distribution
of protein burst
sizes is something
that you expect from the
most basic simple model
that you would
have written down.
So from that same point,
it's not a surprise.
It is often assumed this
thing should be geometrically
distributed, and it was.
And that's wonderful.
From my standpoint, I think
that even things that we
assume to be true,
we should still
check to see if they are true.
And in other cases, they
may not be, and so forth.
Are there any questions
about this paper?
No?
OK.
Then I will see
you our next class.